we've been um touring doing standup for
the last year and a half is that right
uh it'll be two years on January
27th dude it's Epic Man have you always
been interested in doing comedy or is it
just something that was like oh I want
to try this no no I I want to say I've
always had a admiration and a respect
for the Craft um I've always been a
supporter uh and I've always had
comedians around me friends and you know
just
haphazardly um and and it wasn't until
one of my comedian Partners his name k
up uh it wasn't until he he just threw
me on stage out of spite you know I did
that to him yeah like 1500 people yeah
so yeah I mean dude that that that's so
uh near to me because both of us are
known for other stuff and we start doing
standup and then it's like oh well this
this guy's doing standup H like ah yeah
I mean people are very very protective
of the art form and um I mean I I
understand it I respect it but at the
same time it's not like they have a
monopoly on laughter or something that's
that's 100% true and let let's be clear
too it's only some people are protective
of it I think that it boils down to
whether people have a mentality of
abundance or a mentality of scarcity
yeah I feel like the only people that
get pissed off are the people that like
that's their only job as a comedian but
if you have like other like lanes and
Outlets people aren't like hating on you
even if that's your only job yeah why
would you hate yeah like if you're
already kind of like solidified and on
your path doing it your way checking off
your goals uh it's the people who aren't
doing that like they ain't doing [__]
you know what I'm saying like the haters
yeah well I mean that's that's like a
generic term but I mean like the how I
feel like okay so if you have not if you
historically ain't been [__] 17 years
consecutively yeah you know what I'm
saying and you doing the same thing
trying just as hard last year as you did
this year as you do the next year and
you ain't been [__] then now or next
year and you just looking for a reason
yeah of course so this is an easy Escape
it's an easy way to say this is why it
hasn't happened for me of course because
people are taking away opportunities
yeah when all it just bro you just ain't
good enough you Spott it you got it
that's yeah and I mean I tell I tell
them all the time it's a long long list
of [__] that they would have
called even if they didn't call me you
know what I'm saying you got Carrot Top
PeeWee Herman you got you know it's a
lot of people man it's not my fault you
know get out there and work harder did
you get nervous going up on stage yeah I
always get nervous going up on stage
would do you get nervous going up on
stage when you're doing music no I'm I'm
I'm abundantly certain that this going
to go phenomenally well but comedy
you're tripping yeah with comedy you
know you know I can't like you know I I
it's it's more of a direct connection
between you and the audience yeah you
know stage you got the DJ you got the
music you got the microphone people's
familiarity with the music is already
going to carry you through the show for
the most part and you have hits that
helps yeah hits and you have the sickest
music of all
time I think it's more than just a
direct connection with the audience it's
a uh if you don't deliver the laughs
right you know like they'll be excited
this was my experience you know announce
steveo they're excited to see me because
they know me oh man and and everybody's
out to have a good time they're rooting
for me because they want to have a good
time they want it to go well I get on
stage there's that excitement and then
the excitement lasts for at maybe like
30 seconds and now it's my job to
deliver and if I'm not providing
entertainment which meets what people
are looking for then it can go south
real fast and that's why it makes sense
to be nervous it's also you
know people have already predetermined
their expectations of you before you
stepped on that stage they have already
pred determined that expectation of what
they
should get from the experience and being
in your presence and the same thing for
me when I step on stage people already
predetermined what they expect from me
now that I've kind of like you know been
consistent with with with being on stage
as a comedian I kind of have added to
those expectations yeah so you know
people have laughed here and there
there's enough people who've come to my
shows and left like oh man I I didn't
know what to expect but I I liked it uh
simply because it's honest you know what
I'm saying it's honest it's not me up
here trying to pretend to be something
that I'm not talking about things that
you see that I obviously go through and
you know giving inside uh commentary on
things that you've probably read about
me you know and um and finding humor and
and and some of the pain that I
experienced over the course of these
years and you know people seem to
appreciate it that's epic when when
you're out doing comedy over the last
two two years what kind of venues are
you performing in I've done all kinds
man I prefer comedy clubs but I've done
some theaters uh I did some
Arenas um stand up Arenas yeah yeah yeah
not me on the bill the headliner but um
I just opened up for Dave Chappelle when
he came W this
Halloween wow I've opened up for
um Mike UPS uh I've opened up for Kevin
hard the boy there you go I did a Comic
View they brought Comic View back okay
um I think uh Kevin and Mike EPS uh
executive producers they brought it back
and I I did a 15 minute set on on an
episode of Comic View um I'll go up in
anywhere if they let me up that's ex
that's excellent man do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude